crazy with eric henson's game right now  but you were pushing for a while  i was pushing but uh he defended really  well and uh  couldn't come up with anything so um  gotta gotta play catch up still  how how tiresome is it to play that much  catch up in a week  it's it's very tiresome but i i i knew  what i signed up for that uh every match  was going to be a bit of a struggle  um today uh today's match though i mean  he's really good like he's just it feels  like he's getting stronger every month  which i can't see he probably is 16. he  really is and that's that's scary i'm  i'm i'm trying my best uh but uh  hopefully i can uh  do a bit better uh the second half of  this match thank you erika good luck to  you thanks